BIRT يعيد بناء شمال السويد قرية صغيرة
حيث يمكنك أن تضيء بالأضواء السحرية
في الليل وأثناء النهار
يمكنك القلق بشأن الغموض الكبير ، نعم في
مكان ما بين هذا المنزل وهذه
تحافظ على صف من الأشجار العملاقة والرنة
هناك لغز Centurion الذي
يتضمن الجبن نعم  هذه الكرة الكبيرة من
الجبن وكذلك بالنسبة لجميع المناشف الغامضة ، من
الضروري أن يروى القصص النجمي ، واليوم
يفوتك رودين ، نعم لقطة لطيفة
من الخضار ، تذوق الصلصة مذاق
إمبراطور يسوع السويدي الذي كنت
أصنع السترة حوله وصلصة ما يقرب من 40 عامًا
تم اختراعه الآن منذ وقت طويل في
عام 1872 ، وكان النضج أربعة عشر شهرًا على الأقل
لأن الجبن الجيد
سيستغرق وقتًا ، فهو طعم فريد جدًا ، وله
نكهة مريرة وحليب ، ويحب السويديون الأكبر سنًا
أن يضعوه في الأساس على
كل شيء ولكن من أجل  لسبب ما أنه لا
يمكن تصنيعه في أي مكان آخر في العالم
بخلاف هذا المصنع ، إنه أحد
أعظم الألغاز السويدية التي
حاولنا صنعها في خليج فالكون في
جنوب البلاد.  تحاول السويد أيضًا أن تصنعها في
الصلع وأيضًا في بويل ، لكنها لم
تكن الخضار والجبن الحقيقيين ، فنحن
لا نحصل على المذاق الفريد وطريق النكهة
ولماذا لا يعرف أحد حقًا بعض
اللوم على نيزك ضرب
القرية.  منذ 20000 عام
خلقت هذه البحيرة والتي بدورها تغذي
التربة بالكالسيوم الذي يؤثر على الأبقار
في المنطقة مما يؤثر على الحليب
والجبن التي تنتجها نظرية أخرى
تشير إلى أن الجبن نكهة فريدة
تتأثر بالبكتيريا الموجودة في
هواء المصنع القديم  المبنى أعني أن الهواء
ثمين جدًا لنكهة الجبن ،
فعندما تم عمل ثقوب موسعة للمبنى ،
تم نقل الهواء من المبنى القديم
إلى المبنى الجديد ،
كان هناك مزيج مع نوع
الحليب الذي نستخدمه من الأبقار في
منطقتنا  المنطقة
ممزوجة بالميكروفلورا في
منتجات الألبان الخاصة بنا إذا أطلقنا على هذا السحر أو لا بأس به ،
هناك شيء واحد مؤكد أن هذا الجبن السحري
يبقى على قيد الحياة من قبل الأشخاص الذين يعملون عليه
، أشعر بالتواضع الشديد لحقيقة
أنني  تم حله للعمل مع هذا الجبن ،
إنه نوع من الغموض ولهذا السبب
هو آخر شيء خاص ، هل يمكنك أن
تعطينا الوصفة لا لأن هذا هو
السر الكبير في حل لغز الجبن هذا
ربما تصبح على خير
[موسيقى]